could you please tell us really how you
came to know about the Nobel Prize oh
it's a very interesting story actually I
had been invited to nice france to give
a talk and also to naples italy to give
another talk so i was in nice on on
October twelfth and in the morning and I
was waiting to board the airplane when
the airport attendant came over to me
with a cellular phone and she said are
you dr. ignarro I said yes she said
there's an important phone call from the
United States so she gave me the
cellular phone and I said hello and it
was one of my colleagues was a physician
at UCLA and he usually jokes around with
me and so on and he calls me all the
time he asked me how I was doing how was
the weather how was the trip and I said
fine fine but I'm very busy i have to
get on the plane let me call you when i
get to naples in about an hour he said
okay but before you go I have to tell
you something and I said well please
make it in a hurry because I have to
board the plane and he said you won the
Nobel Prize and then we got disconnected
the cellular phone you know the power
was lost we got disconnected and I gave
back the phone and I boarded the plane
but I never really knew if I had won the
Nobel Prize or not and so I boarded the
plane and I remember I was looking at
the people on the plane I thought maybe
if it was true maybe this was in the
newspaper and people would recognize my
face and so I kept looking at everybody
to see if anybody would recognize me but
nobody recognized me so I sat down and
again I wasn't sure so about an hour
later when the plane landed in Naples
the professor who invited me to give a
talk at the University of Naples was
waiting for me not in the terminal
building where you wait for most people
who are coming in by plane but he was
actually standing on the runway was the
airport police waving a piece of paper
and so I looked at him from me from the
window of the airplane
I'm wondering what what is he doing
there and then I suspected that you know
maybe he's trying to tell me some
important news maybe maybe it is true so
I exited the plane and I get to the
ground and he says Lou Lou have you
heard the news and I said no no I didn't
want to tell him what i heard i said no
i haven't heard any news he said quickly
come over here and read this so he holds
up this piece of paper but it was
written later I found out it was written
in Swedish it was the press release i
guess but i recognized the first five
letters of this very long word and it
started off n OB al and then my eyes
drifted downward and i saw my name and
and i actually dropped to the ground i
was so so surprised and so jubilant and
and that's how I first heard about the
Nobel Prize far away from home
you